hey everybody welcome back to Vivaro in
this episode I'm going to be adding a
lot more detail around the console
mostly working on some coaster supports
some extra towers but first a telescope
right here which is a detail that I
wanted to add in order to give a bit of
a counterweight to the overwhelming
presence of the gear and the build up to
now I wanted some sort of a protruding
structure that really points to what
what's going to be the front of the car
so kind of like the front of a ship kind
of thing and in the end I figured
something that sort of looks like a gun
would work best but instead of a gun I
wanted to go for something a little bit
more peaceful so we're going with a
enormous telescope and this thing is
really oversized and not really that
realistic I'm not too knowledgeable
about telescopes I just wanted to get
the very basic part of the tube that
forms the telescope in here and support
that with a pretty strange bunch of
machinery and underneath it actually I
have like the scope which is used to
find what you're aiming for and I'm not
sure how much sense that really makes
sense you usually find them on the top
or probably on the side of a telescope
but in this case this was about the only
place where I felt it would fit in and
also this telescope is more than just a
little bit oversized so I figured it
would look best to put the finest scope
right down there beneath the rest of the
telescope and of course I wanted some
sort of way to actually tune the
telescope and instead of just putting a
little simple tune elements on it a
bunch of useless gears and mechanical
stuff on the outside I don't like the
way to go about doing it which does feel
a little bit like gluing some gears on
it and calling it steampunk but that's
something I'll go with in this case it
just looks too good to skip out on and
I'm not leaving that knowledge ball but
telescopes anyway but that's just about
it for the telescopes I'm going to come
back to it later on to support it but
first I wanted to get some coaster
supports in now the entire island of
course is going to be floating so it's
going to be a
snoring the laws of physics regardless I
will be adding some propellers and
starting with that in this episode but
there's no way that you could hold up
something like this with the technology
then I'm going with but I still wanted
to support the coaster tracks themselves
just to have it seem realistic within
the suspense of disbelief that this is a
floating steampunk castle and I had this
part down here where the coaster really
dips underneath the front of the castle
and it's much lower than anything else
that's going to come very close to it so
the only way I figured that I could
support this part is by adding these
large metal arms which all come forward
from one central point and adding some
very large bulky supports with a bunch
of decorations to make it seem a little
bit more elegant than just large metal
beams and that should pretty much form
the supports here so I made the base and
decided to not go with the large beams
in the middle because it ended up being
a very busy looking in the end so I
eventually scrapped that idea after
testing it with a few arms over here and
that just didn't work out as well so I
eventually just remove these things but
this is the very basic look of the front
of the car so we're gonna have a bit of
a wall before you actually reach the end
there but there is going to be some
large structure that holds up all of
these supports and what's underneath the
telescope right here but that's
something that I will get into in the
next episodes or something I don't quite
want to spoil first I wanted to get into
the mechanism which holds up to
telescope and is used to actually aim it
and something that's kind of weird about
this is that usually you just mount a
telescope on some sort of support and
that's usually where you also have the
point where it can rotate but in this
case this thing just feels way too heavy
and especially with the island ending
right underneath the telescope it felt
like there was no way to support it from
down under there so instead I thought it
might be fun to add a large metal ring
on which the tellus
can fly or not really fly on which the
telescope can glide back and forth and
I'm not sure really how well that
actually works but it's something that I
really wanted to try over here because
it's something that I figured it would
look really good and it's a bit of a
play between the half circle of the
telescope and the entire circle of the
gear as well because they're sort of
these interlocking circles with the
telescope pointing out from the center
of it which all sounds really weird and
crazy but it's it's something that I
wanted to put together just in this way
because I just like the way it looks
it's it's pretty dynamic and interesting
to look at from the Front's of the
castle here so I was doing that but I
didn't have anything to hold up this
front or even create some sort of front
facade for the castle so why would I
wanted to go into after this is actually
making the front facade which is a bit
of a challenge since the telescope is
ticking right through it and I didn't
want to make anything too fancy it has
to be something which would look like it
is the front of the building without
having all of these problems the
building issues like having large doors
or having a large pediment in the front
because there is simply no room for that
with the telescope in front of it so
what I ended up doing here is just
keeping things very simple at least in
terms of how its laid out it's just a
flat wall with a bunch of pillars on the
side that just form the phone front
facade give it a bit of a classical
front facade look to it without any of
the element elements that would make it
clash with the telescope which sounds a
bit weird at this point but it's
definitely gonna make more sense later
on in this episode and especially in the
next episode when I finish this entire
area because everything is very tightly
packed together we have the telescope
right here but there's going to be a
bunch of towers on the side there are
going to be supports and machinery
elements flying everywhere so I wanted
to make sure that these buildings would
be just about dynamic enough to not feel
like things are sticking into each other
in an awkward way
and a lot of this building was just
smart copy-and-paste work which probably
goes for much of this build as well one
of the things which I really love about
the fact that we can now copy stuff
around without having to keep them on
the grid is the fact that you can
actually just make one pillar and
include the pillar top and the base
everything in that and copy it around
completely freely so while these pillars
might not be placed exactly in same
distances it does allow you to copy
these around and to make double pillars
and stuff like that and that's something
that I haven't done before in this game
and what I wanted to try very quickly
here but what I'll definitely make a
bunch more use of in the future parts of
this build since it works out quite
neatly and just to make things a bit
easier for myself I wanted to get into
the decorations on the walls themselves
after I finish the pillars and kind of
had a clear idea of where I'm going to
have to go and this took a bit of trial
and error to get in all of the details
behind here in the right spots and be
able to actually select them as well
because that was actually quite tough to
be able to select these pieces and bring
them out without selecting the entire
building but in the end I'm quite happy
with how it turned out and it's it's not
the most detailed thing of the built but
it's just something that should fit in
between the pillars then for a little
bit I went back and detailed the tower a
little bit more not that much yet but
it's something that just stuck out since
the the part underneath the tower is
already starting to look finished and I
wanted to get an idea of what this part
of the tower itself would look like
before I really went on and perhaps
ended up making things not fit together
so I wanted to quickly finish the
detailing on the tower which again is
just a bunch of pipes and machinery
elements to make it look ivory
steampunky and retro-futuristic and well
generally these pipes are kind of a lazy
kind of elements where you can just add
a lot of them until it looks good so
that's what I was going for this
point just putting a bunch of small
details together until it looks good
pretty much and with that done it's time
to head into the good stuff which is the
first propeller tower I talked about it
a little bit I believe but I'm adding
some propeller towers to hold up the
entire elements about four or six of
them probably in the end it probably
can't really hold up the island
realistically but it should look pretty
neat and at least kind of gives an idea
of how this thing can float in some way
so this was all part of the planning of
the first propeller tower not sure if I
can give these things a fancy name
because that doesn't really sound great
it's also giving me some serious
Gorillaz vibes a hum but anyway yeah
this is the this was just me putting
that down for an idea of where I'm gonna
place that because before I went into
the tower itself actually wanted to
finish something which is going to stand
very close to the tower and therefore I
wanted to finish this before I went into
the tower and ended up making things not
fit neatly together I wanted to make the
supports underneath the coaster which
are a little bit Baron 1898 inspired a
little bit RMC inspired just some iron
works which connect together in some
different ways to give the coaster just
enough supports like a realistic
intimate wood while at the same time
maintaining that steampunk feel the
reason that I didn't want to go for the
in-game supports here by the way is that
they would totally ruin all my plans of
having a floating island since in most
places they would just end up going
toward the ground or not really look
like they're part of the theme so I
might end up supporting a couple of
places of the coaster but most of the
places I actually want to include the
supporting a bit more in the theme which
is definitely something that is inspired
by courses like Baron 1898 and as much
as I think the coaster is kind of
overrated
it's got some of the best support work
that is actually incorporated into the
scenery if not the best it's absolutely
beautiful
but anyway I wanted to do this in sort
of a similar sense and that there are
just some iron work girders over here
that
hold it up and for a while I was
figuring I could have an arch on that
side but in the end actually ended up
placing the arch over here because it
opens up a little bit more space to make
the arch a bit larger since the coaster
underneath it is going more to what the
other side of the supports so I just
made a very large iron arch over here
it's not a perfect arch but it gets the
job done and I'm actually quite happy
with how it looked also it I didn't want
to make it too overbearing since there's
going to be a bunch of scenery around
this and it's going to be tough to see
what it's going to look like when
everything is done but I wanted more
like a very subtle support system rather
than supports claiming all of the
attention like they kind of do with
Baron 1898 so they're a bit more
withdrawn and simple now for the really
really good stuff I have no the actual
good stuff that I was teasing a little
bit out of the tower of the propeller
that I have on the side here which is
more like a turrets
it's just that towers and telescopes
sounded a bit better than towers and
telescopes and turrets so we're going
with that name but it's the turrets in a
sense that that it's really just a small
thing that comes out of the supporting
bridge that I'll have on this side and
it's a bit of a an experimentation as
well with making one quarter of a tower
and take decorating that as much as I
can and when that's done just copy
pasting that tower around four times
which is something that I've done a lot
ever since we got the the copy paste in
the game which is the beginning pretty
much if I'm right but anyway that's
something which have done a lot before
but not really with the level of detail
that I have over here and definitely
being able to copy around separate
scenery items with the 3d gizmo helps
along with making even little towers
like these which are copied around in
quarter sections a lot more detailed so
I really wanted to get out everything
that I could to detail those little
things so there are some iron works with
the signs that they belong to very
sneaky hidden inside the pillars that
they're placed on the side of
and I really wanted to get into making a
custom roof for this building as well
because I already have customers for
every single tower so why not this one
no it's just something that I think it
would look best I mean the endgame roofs
are very good but they're never like
exactly what you're thinking of if you
already have an idea in your mind so
that's also why I want to make a lot of
things in this build myself as well so
I'm just detailing at this point and
this is a very clear idea of why this
series is taking much longer than I was
anticipating and why it's kind of
slow-paced not only the sense that know
the time lapses are slow they are sped
up twelve times just as I usually do and
I even cut a lot more in these time
lapses then I usually do as well just to
make them as short as possible and get
as much work done in one time-lapse as I
can it's just that the level of detail
is so stupidly high then I can't do much
more than just a couple of towers and
some smaller details in one episode
especially because I'm making so much
myself and that's the thing that I
suppose I was worrying about a lot
recently and I need to blow off some
steam about right now also steampunk
puns I didn't really get to any of them
in the last episode but I do have a good
list of them anyway that's that's
severely off topic ahem but no it's it's
something that makes this this project
something that I wasn't really sure to
release because it's it's so slow-paced
that you can't really advertise these
videos very well there's not much going
on and the only thing that I can really
advertise for it is that it's a pretty
good look into detailing like an
absolute madman I might be going too far
with some of these things anyway it's
just the slow paced series something to
keep in mind it I'm going to be working
on one building and one coaster and it's
going to take somewhere from 10 to 20
episodes most likely yeah that's
something to prepare for for me as well
anyway finishing of the tower over here
which definitely has a very different
shape from the ingame roof it's a little
bit more flats and I wanted to get that
that black part on top of it this part
was also kind of inspired by some
fantasy final fantasy concept art that I
like literally anything that steampunk
there are so many things that are
steampunk that I can be inspiring
actually Baron 1898 which I went on
recently does have a very steampunk
station which I figured a lot of that
sort of steam engine machinery I could
very well use in this coaster as well
but um yeah I've seen a couple of well
quite a few actually of steampunk
concept arts that have these towers on
the side of airships where they hold up
the ship with propellers and that's when
I'm taking the inspiration for these
turrets for I'm not sure if they're
gonna be the only thing that support
this build by the way I know that I'm
not going to make this realistic in any
sense and I know I've talked about it
it's just that you know these turrets
are really just the only thing in it the
entire build has going for it so far and
that's that's not a lot so that's
something to maybe worry about but then
again this is the type of build where
you're really going mostly for the look
and ignoring just about anything else
even though I do wanna try and make this
just about as realistic realistic as I
could I'm still building a steampunk
floating castle so that's of course
something I'm going to keep in mind here
as well it's it's mostly geared towards
getting the largest amount of detail
that I can and experimenting a lot with
the in-game pieces and hopefully the one
thing that I do want to try and do with
the series as much as I can it is
getting getting some unique elements for
each episode so on this one we have the
telescope and to some degrees some of
the machinery around it and the supports
of the coaster and in the following
episodes I I do hope to make some more
of these smaller details that you would
kind of almost expect you would have to
import it into the game yourself but
that you could actually make if you
combine the pieces especially the
smaller pieces in some smaller ways now
here I'm just working on one of the
towers on the side of the bottom part of
the castle here I'm not going to be
adding too much over here because
spoiler warning I'll be adding eight
dome on the side of the castle which is
going to make it very look out which is
going to make it look very similar to
the culture which I have in
Phantasy belly which by the way yes it
is most likely canceled and I won't
return to it but it's going to make it
look very similar to that which is one
thing that I'm not entirely sure about
how well that's actually going to work
out in the end but I wanted something to
give to provide the major bulk of the
building you can't just have an entire
building
that's just towers without it ended up
ending up looking like a large jumbled
mess and not being able to pay as much
attention to the details I'm not saying
that a building which is just a bunch of
towers I can't be beautiful as well
especially in concept art it's just a
kind of case where the individual towers
of course don't pop out as much on their
own and especially with the level of
detail that I'm going for here and how
unique the town so far are that's
something I don't want to do and there
is quite a large footprint that I have
to fill it in here so the dome is gonna
fill in the majority of the of the body
of the console and that's why I actually
wanted to make this tower so low and set
a bit more to the bank
it might look very weird in the way that
the building is composed right now but
it gives a bit of space for the dome to
shine through which is gonna sit just in
between the dome and the turrets if you
look from the perspective that the
camera is looking from right now a
little bit to the right and yeah that's
why I wanted to make this tower on the
side as an extra detail and as a way to
prevent the building from looking very
boxy and adding some extra details in
there but it's it's one that's quite
small and I suppose it knows its place
as a little detail but not really a very
noticeable prominent Tower on the side
here and for the rest it's it is already
starting to look like more of the same
using many of the details in many
similar ways I did still want to make a
unique roof and put together the details
in different ways that I've done so far
but at this point you could probably see
many of the elements returning that I've
used many times before so a lot of the
wooden posts that are used to
make the roofs and to make the spires
and the pointy bits on top of them a lot
of the primitive elements actually that
I use for many of the golden details and
elements on top of the spires are coming
back many times and the fountain pieces
that I love using to make all of the
sides then like the basis for the towers
are an object then I want coming back a
lot as well so you can definitely tell
which kinds of objects I'm going to be
working with most throughout this series
I do want to break that up a little bit
because I'm already starting to feel
like I'm entering like this sort of zone
where the theme is getting comfortable
and that's actually what I want to avoid
because it's well it's something that
can definitely make your building
process a lot faster and more efficient
it's something that can end up making
things not as creative or not as
inventive so I don't want to be I don't
to become too comfortable with the theme
but yeah you can definitely tell some
problems some things that are coming
back quite a bit here which is also why
I'll figure out some different things to
build in this build other than towers
and things that I've been doing so far
but anyway I've been talking a lot about
the future this is almost the end of
this episode just wanted to quickly add
a steam machine over here to control
where the telescope is going but a lot
of this area will be finished and and
connected in the next episode so I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode thank you
guys for watching and I'll see you in
the next video
[Music]
the
[Music]
Oh
you
[Music]